[Music]
if you're not
over how epic black widow is raise your
hand
while there's no doubt scarlett
johansson brought natasha romanov to
life perfectly
it couldn't have been done without the
added touch of special effects
so what exactly does black widow's butt
kicking and motorcycle riding look like
without the help of cgi
stunt doubles and vfx we'll give you a
hint
drastically different that's not up to
you
what would an avengers film be without
an epic slow-mo walk sequence
while this end game scene may seem
straightforward at first glance
watching the behind the scenes footage
will tell you otherwise
the vfx team played a huge role in the
moment by adding in their white time
traveling suits
while filming all of the actors
including scarlet were wearing motion
capture suits instead
the special effects team actually helped
out the costume department with this one
the design for the costume wasn't
complete yet so they decided on adding
it digitally
black widow's big face reveal while
acting as councilwoman holly had us
shook but it probably left you with a
lot of how
questions scarlett along with holly's
actress
jenny agata both filmed this scene
separately on a green screen and then
the rest was left to the magical powers
of vfx to sync and create that
transition
can you give her a lesson if you can
impress tony stark you know you're doing
something right scarlett performed this
entire fight scene with happy herself
it did take quite a few weeks of
training with her stunt double heidi
money maker but by the end of it she was
flipping jon favreau on his back like
it was her job it kind of was although
heidi did admit there was a part of the
fight sequence that she had to jump in
and film herself
the stunt included a one-handed
cartwheel that led to her legs around
his neck
so that she was able to push him to the
ground and flip him over
the truth is during this age of ultron
scene scarlett johansson was
barely present some shots were done
using a motorcycle rig and
an enormous green screen background
others were complemented with additional
footage that was added on with vfx
later on and captain america's shield
without special effects it was nothing
more than a tennis ball
the coolest part about the scene though
might be the fact that scarlett
and her stunt double were made custom
motorcycles just for the marvel films
stunt double heidi had to take over for
a lot of this epic hallway sequence in
iron man 2. however
scarlett was determined to film as much
as possible and trained for four hours a
day
for eight weeks to be able to include
parts that were all her
but it wasn't without some hesitancy
from the actress
when i first saw the sequence that they
wanted me to do and it was completed and
choreographed
i just thought to myself oh my god how
am i gonna do this
to keep her safe she was attached to a
harness a lot of the time
in the end having her included in the
scene added even more realism to
everything
the last five years i've been trying to
do one thing get to right here
special effects were helping out black
widow right until the very end
her trip to vormir with hawkeye might be
one of the most vfx heavy scenes she was
a part of
this soulful adventure was filmed in
front of a large blue screen with the
cliff edge being a platform that was
constructed in the studio
a harness and wire were used for the
final moment of black widow's story
excuse us while we cry for a second
play it later put some debris is coming
down you know what i mean like
you know you can feel the blast this
bucky car chase scene didn't look
anything like the extravagant final cut
we saw unfold on our screen
bucky's actor sebastian stan wasn't even
present for this part of the filming
scarlett and chris evans filmed at a
standstill in a studio car
in front of a green screen what makes
the whole behind the scenes moment even
more lackluster is that they also filmed
without sound effects they instead took
directions on where to look
and where to shoot from the director
the scene where widow takes on bucky
single-handedly is another moment that
looks completely different without the
marvel movie magic
scarlett and sebastian performed this
scene themselves
but it wasn't without some added safety
and effects scarlett was attached to a
harness and a wire so that she could
keep her balance on sebastian's shoulder
and then safely get pushed off like the
car chase scene
all of the action and sound effects in
the final cut weren't present while they
were filming
payload's secure thanks sam don't thank
me
i'm not thinking that thing despite her
dedication to stunts and fight training
in the past this moment was just a
little too
high caliber and dangerous for scarlett
to attempt this means she was nowhere in
sight for the filming of this sequence
it was shot with stunt doubles all
around according to the filmmakers this
helped the scene turn out more realistic
instead of having to film multiple cuts
with shots of scarlet
intertwined well you pulled this off i
remember a time when that seemed pretty
impossible too
before black widow and hulk kindled
their little romance
things were pretty rough rough as in he
chased her down while destroying
everything in his path however for the
filming of scenes like this
scarlett would film with a green screen
behind her oh thank god
so they'd be able to add the hulk in
later digitally
the explosions we see in the behind the
scenes were controlled pyrotechnics
meant to imitate hulk's destruction
remember the huge boat featured in the
opening scenes of winter soldier
completely vfx check out this wild
breakdown
for filming scarlett chris and the rest
of the cast actually just shot in a
studio surrounded by a massive green
screen
scarlett still came flying in but she
was all decked out in a harness for
safety and instead of falling from a
plane it was just from her place a
couple of feet in the air
i'm gonna get a view like this we all
know that marvel didn't actually destroy
new york city for this battle
but we also didn't expect it to be
filmed the way it was
the moment that included black widow was
shot entirely in studio with the actors
surrounded by a ginormous green screen
the rubble of new york was added in with
vfx later
apart from a few props like the classic
new york taxis
scarlett also had some help from her son
team to execute
all of the fight sequences she had who
here hasn't been to space
besides the actual actors there wasn't
much that was there during the filming
of black widow's first adventure to
space
and even then bradley cooper wasn't
sitting in the pilot seat in place of
his character rocket
rocket along with the entire spaceship
and captain marvel's suit were added in
using computerized special effects if
you look
closely you can see the motion capture
dots that brie larson had to wear
in this scene this earth-shattering or
should we say earth blipping battle in
infinity war
was filmed on location but they needed
multiple blue screens to transform an
ordinary field into the battlegrounds we
saw in the final cut
they even have blue screen platforms to
add dimension
and help the actors by adding some
realism to it all
with black widow on the front lines of
the war she was in the midst of
all the special effects like the wakanda
shields that were non-existent behind
the scenes
filming these moments took a lot of
imagination on the actors and director's
part
mark ruffalo hasn't been shy about how
embarrassed he was to have to wear a
full motion capture suit while filming
amongst
the other avengers i've seen worse but
during this brainstorming session it
definitely helped out scarlett
having mark act out the scene instead of
just digitally adding in hulk afterward
allowed scarlett to carry out a proper
conversation instead of her having to
rely
on imagination scarlett had her work cut
out for her when it came to the avengers
films
eight weeks of training for just one
scene yikes
luckily the special effects teams were
able to give her a hand when it came to
making the scenes look
epic what scene do you think looks the
most different without special effects
let us know in the comment section below
thanks for watching